écoutez moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que évidemment avec les vaccins
dont on vit à nouveau ce qu'on avait
vécu au de lui avec les masques les
masques à l'époque on en avait pas et
est devenu un sujet stratégique un sujet
de la diplomatie aujourd'hui avec le
vaccin sur une chose la russie et la
chine essaie de faire valoir sa capacité
de fournir des vaccins au reste du monde
mais d'ailleurs les vaccins passée
population mais il en exporte beaucoup
et ils font des gens une tâche de les
propagandes oui en disant nous sommes
des fournisseurs de vaccins
mais voilà les zones et que je vous
donnais tout à l'heure voilà les données
il faut le savoir et nous les européens
nous sommes le plus grand final nous
voulons la plus grande quantité d'argent
ocovas 2 milliard d'euros personne fait
plus que nous évidemment il ya certains
pays européens qui ont préféré aller
chercher les vaccins russe parce que
c'était à court de la production d'oeufs
européenne moi même à moscou ce que j'ai
moi de là rappelé jeudi que plus il y
aura des vaccins plus acérées mais pour
tout le monde mais des vaccins qu'ils
soient certifiés par l'agencé européenne
des médicaments
[Musique]